breaking now from our eight news now
investigators for the first time we're
seeing video of that nightclub brawl
involving two NFL players now we do want
to warn you it is graphic 8 news now
investigator David Charles here now with
all the video that is all new at six
David Brad Denise prosecutors showed
this video to a grand jury leading the
panel to indict New Orleans Saints
running back Alvin Kamara Cincinnati
Bengals cornerback Chris lemons and two
other men for battery now the
surveillance is from cameras in a
hallway outside of Dre's after dark in
the basement of the Cromwell of course
that's on the Strip a witness describing
what you just saw there as a rush of
people and then several men in that
group stomping and hitting that victim
this entire incident lasting just about
15 20 seconds or so you see more people
pull that group away and then they all
leave in a limo now in that limo
prosecutors say Kamara told the group
quote I connected with the expletives
jaw so hard the victim suffering several
injuries including a broken eye socket
he also had shoulder surgery and is
suing Kamara in civil court for 10
million dollars now the NFL did allow
kamaro Kamara that is in lemons to play
all of last season even as metro police
arrested Kamara after he played in the
Pro Bowl of course that was here in Las
Vegas last year Kamara lemons and the
two other men identified in court
transcripts as kamara's manager all face
battery in conspiracy to commit battery
charges kamara's attorney saying in part
their client intends to fight these
allegations at trial they say he was
defending himself and others during that
video you just saw the news now
investigators also learning detectives
work to identify the men from a copy of
kamara's receipt at the club all four
men do in court next week Denise David
thanks for that and you can watch the
videos right now on 8newsnow.com along
with inside of our app you can also look
for more coverage from our 8 News Now
investigators tomorrow